[Music]
thank you
welcome to the data science hangout and
hope everybody's having a great week I'm
Rachel I lead our Pro community at posit
and if you have not been here before
this is our open space to chat about
data Science Leadership questions you're
facing and forgetting to hear about
what's going on in the world of data
across different Industries so we're
here every Thursday at the same time
same place so if you are somewhere in
the future watching this recording on
YouTube you can always add it to your
calendar with the details and include it
below together we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment for
everyone and we all love to hear from
everybody no matter your level of
experience or area of work it's great to
hear from you it's also totally okay to
just listen in here if you don't want to
join in the conversation that's okay too
but there's three ways you can jump in
and ask questions or provide your own
perspective so you can always jump in by
raising your hand here on zoom and I'll
be on the lookout you can put questions
in the zoom chat
and if you do want me to read it out
instead of you maybe you're in a cafe or
your dog's barking or something just put
a little star next to your question in
the zoom chat and then we also have a
slido link which my colleagues will be
sharing oh Tyler just shared it right
now which they shared in the the chat so
you can ask questions anonymously too
well with all that thank you all so much
for joining us here on this Thursday I'm
so excited excited to have Brad weiner
here with us as my co-host today Brad is
the chief data officer at University of
Colorado Boulder and Brad to get us
going here I'd love to have you just
kind of jump in and introduce yourself
share a little bit about your role and
also something you like to do outside of
work too
yeah great so um thanks so much Rachel I
wanted to thank Rachel and everybody
from the positive team for
um for being here
um and I think on behalf of and hello
Brian good to see you
um and then of course you know it's easy
to thank the community developers but
also just thanks to everyone for the
posit team for helping us
do cool stuff in our jobs that in our
lives so
um it's super fun to get to hang out
with everyone my name is Brad weiner I
am the chief data officer here at the
University of Colorado Boulder
um and I got into this role in a fairly
elliptical way I like many of you are
not technologists to start I was
actually a creative writing major in
college and I will die on this hill that
data science and Technical work is
inherently creative work but over time I
started working for universities and a
lot of different roles and at some point
along the way someone was like hey we
need someone to do some reporting and we
need someone to do this and I've always
liked computers I've always liked
working with them so I'm like yeah sure
I'll give that a shot and uh thought it
was unbelievably fun and interesting and
a really cool puzzle to solve and over
time got more and more and more engaged
in the data side of what colleges and
universities do
there's also a bump in the Road where I
was in graduate school and I took a took
a statistics course by the way I hello
to all my Minnesota Pals out there but I
was at the University of Minnesota and I
had a professor who taught his
statistics classes using our I mean that
was in about 2009 that I was first
introduced to the whole concept of sort
of Open Source data science tools and
just totally fell in love with it just
thought it was the most fun most
interesting thing that could possibly
happen and so that led to my opportunity
to the opportunity to work on a data
science team out in startup land
and then finally to move here to CU
Boulder to lead a data science team here
and then eventually become the chief
Nate officer
um so that's like a little tiny bit of
the journey
um I like to kind of give a quick
overview of of higher ed in general this
is like maybe sort of boring for people
but I imagine many of you have gone to a
university somewhere around the world
and you've had some post-secondary
education and universities are they seem
like they're like this one thing right
but what a university is is it's just
like this collection of thousands of
tiny little units and uh there's this
sort of famous joke that's like we're
hundreds or thousands of little micro
units that are all unified by a common
disagreement over parking or a common
disagreement over the temperatures and
buildings or a common disagreement over
our football team or whatever
but let me just give you like a quick
sense of what you know the the president
of the University of California in the
60s was a guy named Clark Kerr and he
referred to the modern University as a
multi-university so let me just quickly
kind of tell you why we're here so um
the University of Colorado is a research
University we've three missions our
three missions are to engage in research
and to create new knowledge out in the
world
um to teach and uh and
pass that knowledge on to students and
then finally to engage with the public
in What's called the public engagement
Mission and that's translating your
research efforts into things that can be
broadly valuable I mean that really
aligns very closely with what
um open source tools do
um but we also do a lot more we produce
art and creative works we act as a venue
for all kinds of things we're a
community space we have a football team
we have museums we have a bowling alley
we provide health care and patient
treatment we at least at CU Boulder put
a lot of stuff into outer space we
engage in Economic Development with the
community here in Boulder and the state
of Colorado and internationally we at
least at CU we care and feed and sustain
a live Buffalo named Ralphie who runs
around on the football field so the
number of things that a single
University are engaged in are quite
Limitless and so why I like to lead with
this whole Spiel is that each one of
those results in a very like almost
Limitless number of interesting kind of
data science
questions and problems okay so that's
sort of the the uh the intro
um and so I definitely want to take most
of the time to answer questions for you
but
um but just if you could imagine all of
that complexity
every single one of those components can
land as a data question and so why I am
here and why our teams are here is to
try and think through ways to make the
student experience better to make the
faculty experience better to make the
staff experience better to make us work
more effectively work more efficiently
to make it so that the people of
Colorado have the best possible
um university that they can have
so with that I'm loving this chat by the
way
I love that
I love that intro too but we forgot one
thing what do you like to do outside of
work as well what do I like to do
outside of work so um recently I decided
I needed to spend less time in front of
a screen and so I started taking piano
lessons which I encourage anyone
especially if you're sort of later in
life or midlife to just try something
totally new I walk into these piano
lessons and the person before me is an
eight-year-old girl who's amazing and
I'm like
barely making it through the trouble
staff
um so I've really been enjoying learning
learning to play piano and getting back
into music
I love that yeah thanks for that
question Rachel yeah I just uh started
taking guitar lessons a few weeks ago
too so like actually learning music
theory again after like fourth grade
flute class
Patrick I see you have your hand raised
here to jump in uh with a question you
want to jump in
thanks Rachel and hi everybody and
thanks Brad for being here I appreciate
your time uh first I just want to say I
I love universities too and like their
weirdness and flaws and all the kind of
strange things about them uh but but
your enthusiasm for it and the way you
articulated that just now was was
awesome so thank you very much I really
I really enjoyed that and appreciate how
uh how into it you are
um my question is is uh specific to the
University of system if you have any
examples of where you have really like
influenced an Institutional level
decision
um or maybe maybe just for a school or
Department uh but where you all have
really shaped something like a real
impact story from uh from your data
science work for the University
yeah that's a great question and so um
Patrick I'm guessing you have experience
in Academia or in higher ed you seem to
know the space pretty well
um
doing the data work is the easy part
getting people to actually use the data
and sort of inform policies is is much
trickier
um and I also always like to point to
the fact that it really does take a
village you know we need all kinds of
people to be invested and interested in
um in a project but there is one that
we've sort of been pointing to lately
which was just released publicly to um
you know kind of quietly because it
happened during finals but one of the
things that that we've thought a lot
about is ways to make it so that
students have as easy of an experience
as possible because we really really
want students to be successful not just
because that's like our core our core
Mission but we're measured on that all
universities are measured on that in a
lot of ways and students want to go to a
place where they're going to be
successful so we're constantly looking
for
what I would consider and I I know this
is kind of gross terminology for people
in high red but
building a college degree really is a
supply chain problem you know you need
to have all of these constituent parts
and they need to land at the right time
and there's tons of dependencies and
those dependencies need to be built out
years in advance so if we don't have
enough chemistry Labs that student
doesn't get to take chemistry and if not
enough students take chemistry they
don't have the
required courses and they can't graduate
so we're constantly looking for these
things and one of the things that we
have found
is that students found that the prices
of their textbooks to be
um to be something of a barrier
and one of the things that we actually
found we're not only trying to graduate
students but we're trying to graduate
everybody as equitably as possible if if
the experience is
one way for some students in one way for
another group of students that is not
considered success and so what we were
finding and what we had heard and what
we learned is that students were
potentially choosing which courses to
take based on the cost of the textbooks
and there's also a little bit of this
this mode of understanding now that the
students of today are used to
subscription Services nobody ever thinks
like oh how many songs did I listen to
on Spotify am I getting my money's worth
they're just like used to or Netflix or
these models where you just pay one
price and you get everything and it
doesn't matter how much use it or how
little you use it so Patrick to answer
your question this is kind of the long
way around but to answer your question
we just recently
um deployed and it's you can read about
it publicly but or one of the first you
know handful maybe dozen or 15 schools
that have gone in on this kind of
bookstore Equity access model which is
basically students pay one price
and that gives them the sort of
financial stability the predictability
in their budgets their ability to budget
on books but also the ability to be
really flexible in what they take and
um
and by paying that one price they get
day one what we call Day One digital
access and there's also evidence that
students who I mean think about your
college days right you go and you take a
class the professor gives the old like
look to your left look to your right one
of you is going to fail and you're like
I'm out of here and so then what you
have to do is you have to go you have to
go back to the bookstore you have to
return that book and so we have found
and there's evidence that having digital
immediate access to your books is
actually a Student Success lever and so
for a variety of reasons we wanted to
implement this program
and one of the things that we were asked
to do is
what price should the bundle be
and if any of you have worked in pricing
it's a really complicated problem if the
price is too high nobody participates
and the whole thing kind of collapses on
itself and if it's too low you don't
cover your costs
and so we had a whole team of people who
are sort of thinking through that
problem
um and uh
Rachel was very clear she's like you you
do not need to to chill for posit but we
are happy to say that we used our super
sweet posit workbench set up to simulate
a whole bunch of different options uh
the data science team did that and we
were able to
um to help them
provide to guide them on what that price
was and it got deployed out and so next
year from what I understand all
undergraduates at CU Boulder will pay
279 dollars a semester
um and get all of their books
um on day one
and if they drop a class then those
books go away and the new ones come in
and they just have access to their books
Patrick I think it'll be valuable to
follow up with me a year from now and
see how well we did because this is a uh
an un it's a Known Unknown we're gonna
have to see uh see where I landed
that is a great example thank you very
much and really not what I was expecting
in terms of the the example you'd choose
but but just kind of demonstrates how
how broad the impact could be in in an
area that's so like complex and diverse
like you described so so thank you that
is uh that's wonderful yep you uh you
got it sorry I need to read this chat is
less than I was paying 20 years ago so
that's yeah
so um well we'll see how we do uh yeah
that's amazing there's a lot of a lot of
love for that example in the the chat
here too yeah I see um Abigail you had
asked the question in the chat a little
bit earlier do you want to jump in here
thanks Rachel yeah this is something
like multiple organizations I've been
part of I've tried to been trying to
figure out like what to use for database
so I see you guys are doing like a lot
of tablet dashboards of public what was
sort of how did you think that through
his organization like what database is
supposed to use
um so that is a great question
um I'm sorry your name is Abigail I
didn't see where I got highlight oh
awesome so thanks for that great
question
um databiz is
eternally complicated because the um
the technology is always moving and so
um and then I I think it's it's also
fair to point out that higher ed tends
to be a fairly conservative industry and
it tends to buy things in like big ways
so hey we want to spin up a a posit
server uh and just test it out on 10
users
is is usually a little bit different
than like what is the best way that we
can like use our tremendous buying power
to have everybody in the same tool
um and so
it's always kind of striking a balance
but
um a lot of universities have gone in
pretty deep on
um
I don't know if I'm allowed to say it
but on Tableau I if a third of you hang
up right now I I will not blame you
um you can say whatever you want no I
know but I'm just uh
so so anyway
um Tableau is kind of an industry
standard across what's called
institutional research so
um universities have all these
compliance regulations they need to
report out a bunch of stuff and
um
and so Tableau is just like pretty
commonly used and has been for about the
last 10 years so we do use uh no no
comment Bill uh but you're potentially
correct uh but one of the things that
we're constantly thinking through are
ways to leverage more modern technology
and then one of the things that's uh
that's a really interesting problem
space is that Tableau doesn't
necessarily provide semantic HTML
underneath as part of its API calls and
what that means is that it's actually a
little bit difficult to access with
screen readers and of course we're a
public university we put out a bunch of
public data and one of the things we
want to make sure we do is have as
accessible of
um visualizations and an accessible
access to our information as possible
and so
um
so Tableau provides a ton of value for a
lot of reasons and people really like
being able to explore the data but we
are also looking at at other ways to
potentially visualize information and
put out data there's also just people
who want to use open source tools and so
um there's always the conversation of
like
how big can we scale things like flask
or streamlit or shiny and I know that
those are amazing options and and I love
them but we we haven't gotten to a point
of like sort of like institution-wide
buy-in so we pick Abigail in the way
that we pick a lot of things which is
through a process called satisficing
which is like well the university up the
road is doing it seems good enough it'll
be fine
we'll go with that and then we're mostly
happy with what we get until something
better comes along
and all of the open source questions I
totally agree with
um and we just haven't gotten there yet
um so those of you who work in like your
cool startup with 50 people and you're
like oh well we were in streamlit for
three weeks and it didn't work for this
now we're going to Pivot over to shiny
or whatever
um it's just a lot harder for us to move
the sort of gravity of such a big
organization
um
and I will say Tableau has a lot of
advantages it has a lot of functionality
although it does not have a spell check
so
what does that mean
I uh I see Lisa had a follow-up to your
story that you shared about the book
pricing Lisa do you want to jump in
all right I'm I'm launching right now
which is rather early for Minnesota but
so it is
um yeah I was just curious if you shared
out and maybe it's a little too early
any of the
um findings about
the books because I know having been in
Academia that you know at least
McAllister was sort of thinking about
that problem as well
yeah we're still pretty new to it there
are and
I read all like seemingly hasn't like
never has a mythical first mover but
there are a couple of schools that have
gone in on this including University of
California at Davis and so they're the
ones who have sort of the most
information about it
um I would be happy to share and you
know talk with the people who actually
built this out but right now we are
launching it for this fall and so it'll
be a little while before we have any
like real outcome data but of course the
really exciting part will be can we
measure whether or not that particular
intervention had an impact on Student
Success
um and so probably a year or two years
from now we'll have some like real data
on
what it all meant right now we were just
trying to get the thing out the door and
put a price on it but all the cool stuff
is yet to happen
also hi Lisa
I know Lisa from uh you know
tangentially through the the Twin Cities
data science community so it's good to
see good to see my Minnesota peeps in
here
love that likewise
I see yeah
oh sorry I see Alan you had asked a
question a little bit earlier in the
chat do you want to jump in here next
yeah sure I brought and everybody that
is super fun today
um I Brad I'm really curious where your
role lives within the institution like
is it are you strongly connected to I.T
are you an Administration and I've got
to think that where you kind of live
organizationally has got impact on like
how work comes to you how you get to
decide what to do how you prioritized
all those kinds of things just if you
could kind of expand on that that'd be
great yeah that's a great question Alan
um I work in the sort of administrative
side
um
but I have a really good uh I have a
colleague who's a chief data officer and
he will basically say that if you run or
work with a data organization and I
would probably apply this to
any of your organizations although I I
only I know my industry best but if you
are a centralized data team and you're
not serving everybody you're failing
um and then maybe that's a little bit
harsh because it might not be set up
that way everywhere but for us we want
to support academic units we want to
support the academic leadership we want
to support Colleges and Schools and
programs just as much as we want to
support the auxiliary units parking in
the bookstore and finance and budget and
enrollment and all of those things so um
our role in the most big picture way is
to support
students faculty and staff and to engage
in those three missions as much as we
possibly can and parsing out where the
boundaries are is really really tough so
people on my team for instance we have a
whole team that does surveys and those
surveys help understand
how students are
um engaging on campus what their sense
of belonging is what type of activities
they're participating in but one of the
things we do is we run what are called
The Faculty course questionnaires for
all of Campus so every time you get to
the end of semester and you go you know
this professor was great or this
professor
wasn't so great all of those data are
sort of publicly available and come
through this data group and that
provides us opportunities to really talk
about Student Success Through the lens
of teaching and learning and through the
lens of
how students are engaging in the
classroom and then of course there's a
whole discipline of kind of what's known
as learning analytics so if you Google
that there's there's all kinds of papers
that are out there but you know the
degree to which students
um in different classes perform on
different types of exercises or
different types of
um
you know in different types of learning
environments
um also matters so
um I a bunch of years ago I had the
opportunity to work with a kind of
multi-institutional team from around the
Big Ten and we were trying to understand
whether or not there was any difference
in academic Performance Based On A
student self-reported gender identity in
introductory stem classes and it was
really fascinating because one it was
like an amazing data engineering problem
you're like well we have a five hour
chemistry class and they have a three
hour chemistry class are those the same
so like harmonizing data across a bunch
of universities was like insanely
complicated but
um it delved really deeply into
you know the unit of analysis of like
the individual course and then of course
you can go even lower like what about
the section what about the instructor
and we are here to support efforts like
that as well which by the way is why
this job is so epically fun because
for three weeks you're talking about
bookstore prices and then you're trying
to figure out like
why courses that have just a midterm and
a final are different from courses that
have a variety of Assessments along the
way so um
I don't know that was kind of a long
answer but the gist is like we live
where we live organizationally but we
have touch points across the university
and if we didn't uh we wouldn't have as
good of an ability to answer the really
hard questions where those two things
land in exactly the same spot you know a
student might not be successful because
they they might have basic needs
problems they might need additional
financial aid they might not have a
sense of belonging they might not be
engaged in the community they might also
just really not be that good at math and
need help with that and all of that is
part of the kind of interconnected sort
of supply chain
that's great thank you it sounds like
such a really fascinating place to to
work with so so much variety of problems
and teams and people
um like juggling a ton but it sounds
really really neat thanks yeah of course
it's completely wild
um but it is fun it's it's an incredible
amount of fun definitely
yeah it's really interesting to hear
about the different variety of problems
you get to work on
I I think when we were we're talking a
bit earlier Brad you mentioned that
they're not there aren't that many
schools today that have a chief data
officer
um and I was wondering for schools who
are maybe like in that
spot of just starting out or like
starting this role Chief date officer if
you have any tips to share with them
yeah I
I get this question
pretty often
um and
so I'm going to get my numbers a little
bit wrong but there's roughly 4 000 or 5
000 institutions in the United States
that receive title for funding
um maybe it's actually probably a little
bit higher but that's everything from
like the California Barber College to
Stanford
um and that's basically title four
funding means you know that they're
eligible for federal student loans or
um
well that's that's probably it they're
probably in the you know in The Higher
Education Act which Congress never
reauthorizes so we're always under like
20 year old rules but there's thousands
and thousands and thousands of
universities and I'll just get on my
soapbox for four seconds to say remember
that number the next time you read in
the New York Times or the Wall Street
Journal or the Washington Post that it's
so hard to get into college
it's not we have so many choices and
most schools admit most students so I
always like to just tell people like
the national media does not paint a very
good picture of the higher ed landscape
at all
um
off the soapbox of those to from what I
understand there's probably
50 or so Chief data officers or fewer
people with that title
um there is a very traditional function
in higher ed called institutional
research which
um sort of reports out all the numbers
of the federal government and they
typically do this kind of work
um so uh I'm not trying to pick on you
Lisa but they're you at McAllister and
in St Paul they actually have a really
amazing institutional research office
that's run by really cool people but if
you've worked in higher ed you've at
some point bumped into your kind of ir
group if you want to know anything about
a university these data are publicly
available and so there's someone who
submits all of those data and it's
usually IR
but what's happening more and more is
institutions are realizing that their
data is this core institutional asset
and that the more value that can be
gotten out of those data
um the better the institution can do and
the better that they can support
students there's also a growing sort of
sense that with the regulatory framework
and with compliance Frameworks and what
the need for data governance and what
the need for sort of more standardized
policies around data that oh look we
have an iPad's key holder look at that
cool nice to see you George
um but uh that the the conversation
around like how do we broadly manage our
data is something that a chief data
officers should be responsible for and I
wouldn't say it's like a weekly thing
but I'd say that probably like once a
month some University reaches out to me
on LinkedIn and is like should we have a
chief data officer what does that mean
what is the sort of construct look like
in higher ed and
um just like
just like it was a growing Trend in
Industry probably over the last 10 years
it's now sort of catching up in in
higher ed
and yes there's a little bit of a chat
iPads is the integrated post deck and
post-secondary Education data system if
you want to know like the number of
enrolled Asian and students at the
University of Texas El Paso it's all in
there and it's publicly available
um thank you yep
I always do a double check on acronyms
yep
um deep show I see you had a question in
the chat do you want to jump in here
next
thanks Rachel if I get a cough attack I
might hand it back to you to complete
the question but we'll be ready
this has been really fascinating to
learn about the setting of University
and kind of problems that you have
um I'm a data scientist at Microsoft and
usually in a business setting I know the
challenge that you spoke of is someone
actually taking the action on the
analysis you're doing is is a really big
Challenge and so on here a lot of times
we don't pick up analysis that could be
interesting because we don't have the
identified stakeholders that would
actually take the action or willing to
take the action but it's also chicken
and egg like if they don't see the
analysis they don't know what possible
action they could take
um so how do you overcome that challenge
how do you pick out the projects how do
you prioritize them considering you
mentioned such a vast variety of
projects you're able to take
yeah I would say
um
carefully
um and imperfectly uh I
you know and I think it's one of the
coolest things and I have to give a hot
tip deposit into Rachel one of the
coolest things about getting in a room
like this is realizing that we all have
the same challenges you know I always
had this idea like oh you work at Amazon
you would work at Microsoft like they've
solved everything right and I've worked
in higher ed right like this this place
it's been here since 1876. it's not
going anywhere soon but it's certainly
decentralized and compartmentalized and
has those same type of organizational
challenges and I'm not bagging on CU I'm
bagging on
you know I'm not even bagging on I'm
describing the reality of being in a
university environment
um
and I would say that
mostly we take on projects in a what
will ostensibly have the largest
potential impact for students or for
what we're trying to do
there's also a little bit of a
conversation that that I think I've I've
thought deeply about deep saw which is
like what is within your span of control
you know and sometimes it's like it's
not um it's you know and this might come
across as
um as the easy Road out but it's like
what are things that that
we could directly impact or influence
um and then there are also times where
it is the decision is made
um in in ways that that I refer to as
like you're bringing water to the desert
where occasionally there are people that
have nothing they are just totally
out in the open and so on that like
dimension of like what's easy for US
versus what's valuable to them is like
such in The Sweet Spot because this
simplest most basic thing it's like
someone's just been asking forever like
all I need is this one thing and to be
able to get at it routinely and you're
like
hold my beer let's focus the the Sprint
let's focus the Cycles on that one thing
and those tend to be the situations
where people come back and they're like
thank you so so much we just needed this
one dashboard
so I would say like
you know
if there's a thing that's easy for you
and high value to someone else that's
that's worthwhile if there's something
where you really feel like
um
it's totally within your Galaxy to be
like hey we had this finding that
finding suggests we shouldn't do this
again you're the person who's directly
responsible for that
don't do that again and like that's
right within your your sort of frame of
reference or within your span of control
um and then of course as someone who
just in case you can't tell I'm kind of
a wacky guy
um I really value fun and joy and being
a little bit weird which I think is okay
and that
one tiny corner of your whole portfolio
should just be that random thing that
seems like it's going to be a ton of fun
to work on because those are the kinds
of things that keep people engaged and a
lot of times it isn't like fun in some
Whimsical way but it's just new like oh
like this bookstore thing that was hard
work it was a complicated problem but it
was probably like five weeks of work it
was time boxed and it was that one thing
and then we passed it on and we're like
ah
that was cool we got to run tens of
thousands of simulations on student
opt-out Behavior now back to our
regularly scheduled program and we kind
of can focus on the the core stuff again
um so is that helpful no it definitely
is and it's great to see like how that
value to effort constant measurement
like is has to be done in almost any
setting
um it's common and it's constant so
thank you so much for sharing and you
did ask another question about like how
do you convince people to use the data
yeah and that is
um I think
you know it just takes time and it takes
trust and it takes effort and
um it's also a recognition that it is
not a linear path of like we're getting
better and better and better and every
single time there's more trust it's like
you go from step one to step two and
that's great and step two to step three
and that's great and then people start
coming to you more and then you totally
Bop something and you're back to step
one because the thing went sideways and
so
I like to think that organizations are
more resilient than we think they are
and that mistakes are sort of less
damaging than we think they are in most
cases yeah and so
people shouldn't be too hard on
themselves if you're like we found this
thing and then people go oh that's cool
right on we're still going to do this
other thing and you're like um but you
might not want to do that because the
data say this
um
and I will say that like higher ed is
especially prone to Folklore and to
you know and to
people believing that their experience
is sort of outweighing data that's
changing a lot but one of the most fun
Parts about working in higher ed and
this is one of the things that I was
talking to Rachel about is that
if you work in some Industries finding
the inefficiencies is really hard
because all of the inefficiencies have
already been found and in higher ed
they're kind of like
all over the place so it's it's pretty
cool
um but to give you guys a quick story
about folklore has anyone ever heard the
myth that students choose which college
they're going to go to based on the
weather on the day that they visit
campus anyone ever been down that one
I have uh uh someone has oh man I was I
really wanted to go to school experience
rainy and terrible that there's no way
I'm going there uh
so um it's maybe a little bit of an
admissions joke but there is some
mythology around that
um I happen to used to work at the
University of Minnesota Minnesota has
famously great weather
um and I tested that assumption and it
turns out to be
false
and that included pulling hour by hour
data
weather data for every single day for
like going back years and years and
years and matching that up with when
students visited but to make it even
more interesting I know I'm talking to a
bunch of data people so you're all gonna
be like how did you do that I actually
calculated not the weather on campus but
I calculated the Delta of the weather on
campus from where they came because I'm
imagining someone from Southern
California being like wow this is
shocking difference
and I modeled that like
in every possible way it was full on P
hacking data torture and I couldn't find
anything to support that assumption
so the next time you hear that one uh
College admissions people
um I tested it in truly one of the worst
climates or the most extreme climates
in America and it's not true
that is such an interesting you know
this is I absolutely love it
thank you for your great question thank
you
I see Michael had asked a question in
the chat and there's star so I'm going
to read it but it was Brad you have any
experiences or stories in using data
science techniques to attempt to measure
the effectiveness of Cu strategic
communication efforts particularly in
terms of things like well I guess this
example example could kind of tie to
this but particularly in terms of things
like recruiting Effectiveness or public
sentiment to University Outreach efforts
yeah that's a copy of the question over
into the chat again too yeah that's a
great question we have a lot of
connections with um what a universities
are called is called like enrollment
management uh and they ask questions
like that all the time
um and I don't want to go you know too
much into the details because uh it's
it's sort of complicated to tease out
um but that is sort of a really common
set of questions that are asked which is
like really what is the effectiveness of
anything what is the effectiveness of a
virtual visit versus an on-campus visit
what is the effectiveness of you know an
email versus a paper mailing
um and those are
um
those are the types of things that are
are routinely asked and that
um you know if you work in an
organization that does sort of marketing
work or does Communications work those
are also I think some of the highest
value conversations to have in data
science land because so often what we do
is very tough to append a specific cost
or a specific sort of Roi to
and so there are things like that where
you're like look you know we sent out
this mailer did it work or did it not we
sent out this
um this email communication did it work
or did it not or what was the effect of
that or what was the effect of that on
different students and
um you know email is basically free so
it's sort of a
Arcane and not very important research
question but there are questions of like
you know this whole combination of
communications what what do those do
um and if they are found to have limited
impact then it's very it's it's easy or
it tends to be easy to make that
argument of like you you really should
pivot these dollars to something else
um and enrollment management is becoming
increasingly scientific I mean it really
is there's a guy's name is Brock tibert
who's gonna be mad at me then I
mentioned his name but he thinks of it
as like a science enrollment science you
know because what you have or you've
millions of high school graduates and
you need to land a class that is big
enough to
um you know it needs to be big enough to
support your operations it needs to be
the right size but you also need to have
that across different majors in
different colleges and different
programs and you need balance across all
these different things so if you
um if you Google the concept of
enrollment management or enrollment
science you'll find a bazillion papers
out there on how this happens and it
starts with like millions and millions
and millions and millions and millions
of people who
um
whose name gets entered into a database
basically and this is also a really
fascinating conversation now because
kovid had a dramatic effect on this
entire industry one of the big things
was that many many more schools are now
no longer requiring the SAT or the act
and in so doing the SAT and the ACT were
the primary source of a lot of these
names and so even like getting the kind
of marketing apparatus going around
student enrollment is a different story
than it was even three to five years ago
um but the the short answer is is yes
and you can find all kinds of resources
and information online about that
uh you can also look me up on LinkedIn
and I used to work at a startup that did
that very thing which was you know email
marketing campaigns to prospective
college students and we had a ton of
research and information on how to do
that well
I'll share your LinkedIn in the chat
here in a second too and I'm sorry if
sometimes I have to be vague I probably
I I don't want to get myself in in hot
water by sharing results that are
probably not shareable
that's okay we're used to that
at least it's not the sports people yeah
so I'm a sports analytics person we did
a thing and it made us win sorry I can't
say anymore
yeah that's a hard one
um Scott I see you had asked the
question earlier
um
I think it was about connect if you want
to jump in
uh yeah sure
um
no appreciate this conversation so I'm
also in the kind of uh higher ed data
analytics and IR world over at
Georgetown
um resonate with a lot of comments about
Tableau and that this space and power bi
and everything around it looker you know
you name it
um but curious you know I think I I have
um kind of found a team of folks who's
really curious and sees an enormous
amount of potential in the open source
space in the orbit of R and Python and
that sort of thing and was curious
whether you whether you have a connect
server up and going whether you're kind
of working with it at a in a production
fashion or whether you've thought about
it or
um you know we're headed in that
direction and it isn't as common in IR
as I might have thought
um so yeah I'm just curious about about
whether you've thought in that space
we have and um I think that it is a uh
certainly a a direction we'd be
interested in pursuing is going into
open source visualization tools
um we do have kind of an interoperable
you know multilingual data science team
and by the way this is only on the
administrative side there are of course
probably hundreds of academic units out
there Scott as you know like who knows
if the physics department has like a
massive server and they're deploying
everything like who knows right very
possible I actually like to give you a
sense of how decentralized higher ed is
it was easier for me to ask Rachel which
other people on cu's campus were using
posit rather than finding out myself so
like that's the world that we're in
um
anybody wants to know who can always ask
me for your own organizations yeah so um
I honestly think that
um
as powerful and as great as those tools
are we still haven't exactly figured out
how to make that happen and some of that
is
kind of tradition and sort of common use
of existing tools and then some of that
is the sort of deployment question which
is like one of the biggest complaints
you get when you're working a big
organizations like please don't give me
something else to log into I my bookmark
bar is already like 900 things
um
but Scott I would
I would think that if
you have the appetite to build it and
then of course there's like the cost
structure around it you know where uh
you know deploying something in posit
isn't free but it's definitely cheaper
than other options
um but I would love to connect and sort
of hear what your what your journey is
like
we we do have a couple people have built
stuff in shiny but then you know we go
well
some end user wants to touch that and
interact with it and that end user is
almost certainly not going to have the
skills to even like fire up uh an IDE
and like run the
the framework
so we're probably in early days on that
but um I think what's probably a more
likely path is that we would
um at least to start and this is all
like just me brainstorming in front of
127 people uh at on a high wire would be
that we would use some of the HTM like
the semantic HTML Frameworks that come
from open source tools so we would
deploy using something like Flex
dashboard or something like
um
something like oh my gosh why is my
brain falling out of my ear
um
High chart which is free use for
academic institutions to just like
deploy HTML web pages and put those out
there I think that would be kind of our
like Gateway into a full deployment of
something like shiny
yeah thanks so much and like I mean ping
you later because again we're at the
front end of this and I think on one
hand see a lot of potential but also
there's just a lot of inertia elsewhere
in the organization as you well know and
as we've already talked about this
morning so yep yep it's a hard hard
problem to move people into a new
technical space
um but Scott I could share some other
paths were going down as well which are
which are pretty cool yeah great thanks
yep
I see Peter you had a follow-up question
I think it was it was maybe on the
weather use case but I'm not sure do you
want to jump in here
oh sure I I was just wondering if if
your your test that question was looking
at all of the institutions that they
were uh that they were applying to or if
they were only able to look at one oh
man if if we had comparative data across
a bunch of Institutions that would be
amazing but it was just for my single
institution
um and so yes I should be a much better
data scientist and put a bunch of
asterisks at the end of that description
that finding was limited and localized
and not generalizable to any institution
beyond the single one that I did the
analysis on over the time period that I
did it on in the population that I did
it on
um so full fully great question
um you know Peter I because we have a
bunch of of
um compliance rules you know there's a
federal law called FERPA which is the
federal education records protection act
there's a lot of stuff that we can't
share and so
um getting a multi-institution level
data set at the unit of analysis of
student level records is really really
complicated
um
and institutions are just very reluctant
to share not necessary like we're very
good at sharing so you know Scott just
asked that question and I have every
confidence Patrick just asked a question
that IR people are institutional
analytics people you all can call me up
and one of the best parts about higher
ed is we all have the same Mission we
are nominally in competition but we're
really trying to just provide an
economic an economic ladder provide
research make the make the world a
little bit better of a place so we're
widely collaborative people can call up
and go hey how did you do this and I
will just straight up tell people how
that worked
um
but the data sharing the ability to do
those multi-institutional analyzes is
quite challenging in in a lot of cases
um but one of the things we're actually
working on here at CU is following after
the healthcare industry we are starting
to develop fully synthetic data sets
that will allow us to do that
um and I don't know many institutions
that are doing that but I'm really
excited for a future where we could
create synthetic data sets that mirror
this essentially the distributions that
exist in a real data set but don't fall
under the data privacy and data
protections of a federal law
yeah but great question Peter
I hope I answered that sufficiently
thank you
um AJ I see you had just asked a
question in the chat you want to jump in
here next
yeah sorry if I missed it maybe earlier
if you mentioned it already but did your
company start off with having a data
office or if not like what sort of
efforts it took to um to create your
role because today a lot of even big
companies sit on piles of data but data
is something just that's lumped under it
normally
uh just wondering your take on that
yeah I
um so I I haven't been here at CU for
for too too long so the history is maybe
a little bit murky but
pretty much every university has had an
office you know that's typically called
institutional research
that has focused on these kind of
analytic questions and then of course
reporting to the various agencies that
require reporting so here in Colorado we
have a bunch of requirements that we
report to the state of Colorado we have
a bunch of connections with the city of
Boulder
um you know to make sure that we're
integrated there we have a bunch of
connections with the federal government
because of title IV funding because of
research funding you know so we have a
lot of data needs to make sure that we
are being in compliance and that we're
being as effective as possible so the
kind of tradition of having a data
office in higher ed goes way back I mean
decades and decades and decades but as
the sort of appetite for data has grown
and as the appetite for people to make
smarter decisions and more sort of data
informed decisions has grown these data
conversations have gotten bigger and
bigger and bigger so do you have someone
who's there to deploy and analyze
surveys do you have somebody who is
there to do research on how faculty are
performing to have to understand how
students are performing to really think
through not just how many questions but
what is the relationship between X and Y
questions and then finally the Third
Kind of layer of that is just like how
do we make the best use of our data in a
secure and a systematic way how do we
democratize it how do we scale it how do
we govern it and so I would say that
like
every University no matter how big or
small I mean the smallest Community
College anywhere
probably has some
even if it's one person some person
who's doing analytic work
um but I think having kind of a
centralized systematic networked
office that's responsible for thinking
about data as an asset is probably a
growing trend
um
but I went to like a Gartner thing a
year or two ago and they had like a
little higher ed table and it was like
oh so you're the six you know but I
imagine that you go a year from now and
there will be 12 and I imagine you go a
year from then there'll be 40 and and
you know higher ed is often last to the
party
um but we kind of track the trends that
go on in Industry quite often
thank you as we oh sorry
oh no I was just saying thank you thank
you of course
thank you all for the great questions
too as we get to the top of the hour
here if there's anything I missed feel
free to raise your hand here on Zoom so
I can see it as well and can call you in
here
um but Brad one question actually one of
my colleagues had had asked this earlier
but they they mentioned they saw
something online that you hosts a
community of practice event and was just
curious to learn like how that came
together and how you publicized it
yeah that's that's a great question so
um it was there was an online community
of practice uh there was sort of a zoom
meeting when I first joined CU and
um you know what we find and I think
this gets back a little bit to deepfest
question which is like how do you get
people to sort of be in in the
experience and you know the College of
Engineering has analysts and you know
all these places have analysts and they
all have people who are working on
similar problems and so the better we
are able to
um
coordinate everybody and the better
we're able to sort of work with
everybody the better we do so we built
out this data Community Practice and it
was a zoom thing and we invited some
guests and I I don't I haven't looked
through the whole list here but I may
have hit some of you up to be guests at
some point uh I know one person in
particular
but anyway we'd have people come in and
talk about data governance or Master
data management or have people come in
and talk about different things and the
idea sort of surfaced with like we're
all kind of tired of staring at each
other on Zoom a little bit this is
amazing because you're all distributed
all over the world but we
have a need to build this community and
so we decided to have an event and we
actually jokingly I mean I named things
so stupidly the biggest problem in
computer science is naming things it's
why I'm never going to be a computer
scientist because I'm terrible at naming
things but we straight up went with like
IRL like we're gonna have a data
Community Practice conference in real
life and let's all get into the room
together and let's focus on a couple
things one we wanted to do some actual
Technical Training and provide that
value to our campus so we had one
training session that was in R in the
Tidy verse and we had another one that
was in Tableau and it was just a chance
to sort of take some real experts in
that and and lift a bunch of boats all
at once
um and then we had some sort of broader
conversations including a keynote
speaker who spoke about the need to
think about data in more Equitable ways
you know we are constantly having this
conversation about
um you know these important
conversations around diversity and
equity and around racism and anti-racism
and
believe it or not if you haven't spent
time thinking about it the way you
collect data the way you capture data
the way you count people matters and so
we brought in someone who is an expert
in this his name is Carson bird we
brought him in from the University of
Michigan to really talk to everybody and
to have a look at thought provoking
conversation around the ways that data
may or may not reflect the communities
that we're trying to represent
um
and then we also gave people the
opportunity to do some lightning talks
which were absolutely amazing just we
invited people from around campus to
basically say for 15 minutes you have
the opportunity to talk about a problem
that is vexing you and
um
I cannot tell you enough how cool it was
and I would recommend it to any of your
organizations to not only stand up a
community of practice and just to get
people together and say like hey what
are you working on what problems do you
have but to occasionally do your best to
try and get everybody together
um in a in a meaningful way because
people walked out of that in my view not
only technically better but with the
ability to sit down and eat lunch with
that person who sits across campus and
is working on on the same thing
so the zoom thing came together before
me but we kind of were like you know
what let's get off soon for a day and a
half and it was
a ton of fun highly recommend
I love that love anything to do with
community that sounds awesome okay we
have a few minutes here so I might just
rapid fire the remaining questions
okay asked
um have you done any analysis of the
chances of a student successfully
finishing a course or failing out
yeah that's a really really common type
of analysis that happens in higher ed is
trying to estimate a student's
likelihood but again we're not here to
be
um you know to filter people out or to
make people feel
um there isn't some sort of channel for
that what it allows us to do is it
allows us to focus our resources like
any predictive model
um the students that might need
additional help so if if we can estimate
that a student might not be successful
in a particular class it isn't like
don't take that class it's what support
can we give you so that you are
successful
thank you I think you answered this one
in the chat but is there a likelihood of
colleges to move to AWS or Azure
completely yeah I mean
hang out in my email for a day and
you'll see that higher ed I mean it's a
massive industry there are thousands of
universities
um and yes there are institutions that
have fully gone into a variety of cloud
environments for a variety of reasons
um so no no doubt
um
cool and one I think maybe one last
question I missed was you talked about
synthetic data sets do you have any
packages you could recommend or
approaches
I would need to get back to you I think
that we're building those in in Python
um and my pythonic chops are a little
bit weaker so I could find out what
we're using and and yes
um
I also I I forgot to drop my favorite
fun fact which is that IPython was a
side project of a grad student at CU
Boulder in the early 2000s so uh
Fernando Perez is a physicist and
realized it wasn't an interactive way to
touch Python and so there's some lab
around here in which IPython and
subsequently Jupiter uh were born so
depending on your view of Cu of Jupiter
notebooks either you're welcome or I'm
sorry
well thank you so much Brad I think that
we got through most if not all the
questions but if there's anything you
missed and anybody wants to send it my
way I can share it with with Brad as
well but it was a pleasure getting to to
learn from you and hear about all the
different projects you're working on
across the university this was awesome
thank you very much everyone thanks for
your time and thanks Rachel and posit
for for having me uh and if anyone has
questions you can uh find me in all the
normal spaces
sounds great thanks everybody